[Musique]
ses tiges charnue courent dans tous les
sens il semble s'étendre à l'infini sur
le sol si son origine précise est un
mystère le pourpier prolifèrent partout
où il fait suffisamment chaud et même en
été dans les jardins européens
pour certains jardiniers c'est une
mauvaise herbe invasive mais en réalité
c'est une petite pépite très résistante
qui a de petites fleurs roses le
pourpier d'un parterre de feuilles
épaisses rempli d'humilité et chargé de
qualité nutritionnelle
le port tout la cao leva ca de son nom
scientifique est riche en antioxydants
en protéines en vitamines a hissé
[Musique]
et en minéraux comme le calcium le
potassium le magnésium et le faire
[Musique]
je
se trouvaient là comme celui de l'aloe
vera peut apaiser des petites blessures
il et cicatrisant anti inflammatoire
anti bactérien hydratant et adoucissant
en décoction il agit sur les
complications digestive peut aider à
faire tomber la fièvre il ya des
propriétés diurétiques
[Musique]
de quoi retenir l'attention du parme le
pôle à vos ressources et de recherche de
martinique il a trouvé encore d'autres
qualités à cette plante sur les tests
réalisés in vivo donc sur des souris sur
des rats on arrive à montrer une
stimulation de la sécrétion d'insuline
est également une diminution de la
production de glucose hépatique à partir
des résultats obtenus l'objectif ou mons
et de valoriser les extraits de cette
plante peut être additionnées d'autres
plantes de martinique qui ont uni fait
aussi en termes d'activité
antidiabétique dans un complément
alimentaire ce complément alimentaire
pourrait utiliser pour justement aider à
la prévention du diabète en martinique
de nouvelles analyses sur l'homme seront
bientôt menées pour confirmer cette
action anti diabétique en attendant on
peut envisager de consommer le pourpier
en salade santé non seulement parce
qu'il est un vrai trésor nutritionnel
mais aussi parce que c'est une plante
robuste qui ne craint aucune maladie
récoltés en à peine deux mois elle
pousse sans grande contrainte un bonheur
à portée de fourchette
mais attention il faut toujours être
prudent si les clients peuvent soigner
nous demander conseil à votre médecin
[Musique]